hi james hi morgan how are you
i'm great all i have to say is move over
morgan freeman
james brolin is my new favorite narrator
i want him to narrate everything
really your voice is so good in this
oh that's so sweet well
uh it certainly was a windfall for me
too
and something that was unexpected and uh
you know i
i've uh i hate to keep repeating myself
but i
i've never gotten a a voiceover job and
it's not like i haven't done a lot of
audition tapes
at the request of my eight my different
agents over the years all have a
department for this
and uh i don't know if well you wouldn't
maybe remember but you know paul newman
a lot of people went to japan for their
voiceover so nobody knew these big
actors
were doing all of these commercials in
other countries you know
at one point and i thought boy that'd be
neat to have then that would be nice to
do without
uh sort of ruining your career by being
by selling
insurance you know anyway so i get a
call from robert
and susan downey that is saying we have
this project we want you to do that's
i said oh let me read it no you don't
get to read it you just get to do it
that's all you know
so i until last friday i knew nothing
about this project uh really
other than what i spoke over the little
film clips
no way okay so when you get a call like
that from susan
and robert what was your first reaction
uh there's gotta be something wrong here
what was their whole idea for wanting
you to be a part of this project i have
no idea
i i still haven't spoken to them and now
we're all
rolling in this success of being number
one in the world
for seven days now straight
and i can't wait to talk to them but uh
robert lost uh someone uh
very close to him about two weeks ago as
an assistant
and he's been very private since then so
um we will eventually uh
talk and laugh and uh because he's
he has an amazing history you know i i
don't know if you have ever seen any of
his early
movies but this is a
wonderful actor who who ended up in
these
um sort of serialized big
over over budgeted movies which i don't
get
but they're huge hits and
uh but i there's a fine actor to me
that's kind of being wasted right now
you know
you have a lot of marvel fans say he's
like the pro most perfectly cast iron
man of all time
yeah yeah if you're going to play iron
man you know yeah but
you know i shouldn't i should keep my
traps shut but that's my feelings
no no
you know what he can do yes yes and and
the same
uh you know with my son um
with avengers you know what are you
doing that picture for you know
you could be really getting your guts
out in another movie you know
so you don't you just love your son in
these films
in that one no or yeah there's been a
couple of them but some of the things
he's done he's done
are very active studio experimental you
know old boy
is wild you know a guy locked in one
room for 20 years and getting out and
trying to figure out who locked him up
and why
you know yeah that's a you know that's
an old korean classic redone by spike
lee and
and and a new country for
old men i mean yeah and
yeah and then and then josh was
nominated for milk
yeah you know people kind of forget you
know
but i just love that about him that he
listened to me and once early on
is don't ever try and be a leading man
your
your uh your career will be this long
but if you're a character actor
it's it's has infinity oh
amazing well yeah then he's had this
fantastic career
with a range of characters that's pretty
much fraud yeah
so you have a really big anniversary
coming up it's your 25th wedding
anniversary to your wife barbra
streisand do you have any any plans
well we keep she's saying to me i don't
want to do anything i don't want to i
don't want to
have to get you anything i don't want
and you know of course
that's death on wheels if the guy
doesn't do something so uh you know i'm
i'm supposing that we're we are going on
a trip in a couple of weeks
at the invite of some friends who are
carrying us off somewhere
and that'll that'll be great but uh
during the
um let's see we we met on july 1st
in in 96
and we're married on july 1st and so
therefore our anniversaries are on july
1st you know oh my goodness that's
amazing yeah
so i gotta come up with something and i
always
kind of wait like uh
ready to pounce on something it always
seems the last week that i find
something worthwhile because she's not
an easy one to please
she's always sweet about it but i can
tell she either loves this
item or she doesn't you know
for 25 years you know you want to make
this a good one
yeah you bet is that uh it's 20
it's 23 married is there i wonder if
there's a a stone
or what there's always something
associated with
the year right yeah definitely yeah you
gotta look into that
i'll look that up when we get up amazing
hey this is such a fun interview with
you thank you so much you're awesome
you too thank you
you